i'm not going to sugarcoat it for you
the economy is in terrible terrible
shape
pessimists say the economy could not
possibly get any worse optimists say it
absolutely can wholesale prices are up a
whopping 10.8 percent over the past year
gas prices have hit their 18th
consecutive day of all-time highs and
the atlanta fed's gdp now estimate is
currently showing
zero percent economic growth meaning
that the u.s is very likely headed for a
recession in order to combat the insane
levels of inflation the federal reserve
announced yesterday that it will be
raising interest rates by 75 basis
points which is the most aggressive rate
hike since 1994 and fed chairman jerome
powell has suggested he may raise rates
by the same aggressive magnitude again
in the near future now we know that the
hike will make it much much more
expensive to borrow money but we don't
know if it will succeed at getting
inflation under control
again we've been expecting progress and
we didn't get that we got we got sort of
the opposite so i also think the
situation really since the
you know the consequences of the ukraine
war become more and more uh
clear
what you're seeing is the situation
getting getting more difficult and you
look around the world i mean lots of
countries are lots of countries are
looking at inflation of 10 percent
and it's largely due to commodities
prices but all over the world
you're seeing um these effects and so
and we're seeing them here gas prices
you know all-time highs and things like
that that's not that's not something we
can do something about
i love the way he begins
we've been expecting progress and we
didn't get that we got sort of the
opposite gee do you think it does
apparently we did get the opposite but i
do love the line actually because powell
is clearly throwing shade at biden
he's saying inflation is coming from the
lockdowns and the war in ukraine and the
energy prices the things that
we here at the fed can't do anything
about he's saying that the crappy
economy is not being caused primarily by
monetary policy it's being caused by
fiscal policy it's being caused by
joe biden and the rest of the geniuses
who are driving the western world off an
economic cliff
we don't need jerome powell to tell us
that our rulers screwed up everything
and most americans know it
the guy who promised to build back
better broke the economy the treasury
secretary who promised us only
transitory inflation gave us record high
prices on pretty much everything and the
quadruple-vaxxed pontiff of public
health himself dr anthony fauci
has just come down with covid
if i were a gambler and we all may soon
need to become gamblers to have a shot
at paying our bills if i were a gambler
i would stake my entire bet
on precisely the opposite of whatever
our genius rulers predict i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from james l carrick
who says i guarantee that the same
people who argued with a straight face
in front of the highest court in new
york that an elephant should be
recognized as a legal person
also believe that it's morally
acceptable to murder a child in the womb
up to or possibly beyond the point of
birth that's true that usually happens
the place you see it
is usually with vegetarian or veganism
there are some pro-life vegans
but generally speaking i'm just speaking
anecdotally here but the plural of
anecdote is data
the vast majority of vegans i know are
extremely
in support of abortion rights that seems
crazy you care about the little delta
smelt but you don't care about the human
babies but it actually does kind of make
sense it's just that people who take an
extremely exalted view of animals and of
the rest of the created world
very often do not have a particularly
exalted view of human beings they kind
of think that we're just human beings
are just like any other created thing
like the elephants or like the monkeys
or like the tumblers or like wood or
plankton or whatever and so they they
don't take a particularly special view
very often it's pretty anti-human but
humans we can do things we do have a
special place in the universe we can fix
our own cars that's why you got to check
out rockauto.com
right now go to rockauto.com enter
knowles in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
buddy mine wrote in to me the other day
he says michael i made a truly terrible
error
i went to the brick and mortar auto
parts store i know he knew what i was
gonna say he goes there and this shop
tried to charge him four
hundred dollars for a party he said that
doesn't seem right what does he do he
opens up rockauto.com he goes to their
super easy to navigate website takes him
two seconds on his phone he sees they've
got the same part for 150 bucks
the guy all he came this close to
overpaying by 250 bucks but what's he do
he goes to rockauto.com he gets it you
don't need to be a pro you can be a
do-it-yourselfer you don't need to go on
some special time of day
rockauto.com has every part that you
need for your car or truck it's got
reliably low prices all the time this is
a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years don't be a
fool do not waste money and throw it out
the window go to rockauto.com get the
brakes shocks carpet wipers headlights
mirrors mufflers lug nuts or any other
part you need make sure you write knolls
in there how did you hear about his box
so they know that we sent you
before we get into just how our society
is crumbling
i i have to get to this
we've wondered where is he
where is the most powerful politician in
america the man who dictated
pretty much every aspect of our national
life for two years dr fauci
es kovid i wish him well i hope he's
fine it seems like he's doing okay they
issued a press release yesterday from
the nih
anthony s fauci medical doctor director
of the national institute of allergy
infectious diseases part of the national
institutes of health and chief medical
advisor to president biden good grief i
got a pause right there this guy sounds
like he's the queen of england
elizabeth ii empress of the realm queen
of india this guy of course he does
because he considers himself the most
important person in the world so he's
got all these titles fauci tested
positive for covid19 on a rapid antigen
test he is fully vaccinated and has been
boosted twice he is currently
experiencing mild symptoms dr fauci will
isolate and continue to work from his
home
he's not recently been in contact with
biden and then they say okay that's it
why why do these guys when they admit
that they got coveted why do they always
have to say that they've been fully
vaccinated and boosted twice
doesn't that seem like it's undercutting
their argument and their credibility
dr fauci himself told us if you take the
vaccine you will not catch covid and
then they move the goal post and they
said no it's not really about preventing
catching covet it's just it's about
mitigating the symptoms but what they
initially told us was the vaccine we're
telling you 100 safe 100 effective it
will stop you from catching kovid so
this guy gets four shots and it doesn't
stop him from catching kovid of course
and he doesn't he doesn't apologize for
it he doesn't admit huh maybe i was
wrong about this and virtually every
other aspect of the epidemic he says no
yeah fatchi got coveted big deal so what
he'll be back oh he'll you thought you
you thought you got rid of me you sheep
no way i'll be back stronger than ever
i'm taking my energy from the
coronavirus that's right i'll get 17
more shots and then i'll run your lives
even more
fauci
is just
the prime example
of our ruling class
incompetent
huge record of failure
and in the face of that failure refuses
ever to change his mind
everything this guy says gets proven
wrong doesn't matter he's that's his
story and he's sticking to it it's not
just fauci he's particularly public but
it's all the rest of them too and
everybody knows it there's a poll just
came out from politico morning
consult this is not exactly a right wing
publication politico liens left the
question is is america on the right
track or the wrong track under biden
almost three-quarters of americans say
america is on the wrong track 74
say that biden's america is going in the
wrong direction
compared to just 26 who say america is
on the right track to put that in
perspective
uh just one month after joe biden was
inaugurated last year they they did a
similar poll 47
said that the nation was headed in the
right direction
so the numbers are way way down 47 to
26. only 53 percent said america was
headed in the wrong direction now that's
obviously up
a lot more
so what is biden going to do what is
this whole ruling class going to do
they've got to blame others they can
never look at themselves they can never
say huh i predicted a bunch of things
and they didn't come true i promised a
bunch of things and i didn't deliver on
those promises i said america was going
to turn around in the right way and
actually everything's gotten worse
remember when trump was president do you
remember when trump was president and
pretty much every single thing in the
country and around the world was better
i can't really think of a counter
example
the only counter example would be covid
because the lockdowns were worse then
and maybe trump bears some
responsibility for letting fauci run
roughshod over him but don't forget
those those lockdowns and the covet
madness
that all of that was being pushed by the
democrats
and trump wasn't able to outfox them and
stop it but that was still being pushed
by
by the dems and then they they've tried
to continue those policies and in some
cases they've been stymied in that by
the courts and and other institutions
and just time and public opinion but
other than that
in in what
measure according to what measure was
anything worse under trump than under
biden it's all worse under biden people
know that and so all biden can do is
blame other people corinne jean-pierre
the white house press secretary
she just said look i know the
inflation's really really bad and one of
the biggest drivers of inflation is
energy costs and yeah it's true we shut
down the oil pipelines and yes it's true
we shut down the new oil and gas leases
but you know we got a solution
hey oil companies stop stop charging so
much
we are we are calling on them to do the
right thing to be patriots here uh and
not to use the war uh as an excuse or as
a as a reason uh to not put to not put
out a production not to not do the
capacity that is needed out there uh so
that the prices can so that the prices
can come down hold on so hold on a
second you're saying that the high gas
prices that's the fault of the gas and
oil companies i could see how you might
be fooled by this if you didn't know
anything about economics or how
companies work but what is kareem
jean-pierre actually saying she's saying
that right now there's this war in
ukraine that was largely caused by
biden's stupid policies with regard to
russia and so you got this war and
that's driving up energy costs and she
doesn't mention that there are other
reasons energy costs are going up namely
that biden's effectively shut down new
american oil production and so anyway
the oil companies these awful american
oil companies they're taking advantage
by driving the prices up
there and what so there's no pressure
for prices to come down
well if that were the case why don't the
oil companies just always keep the
prices up why don't they just steadily
go up forever and ever and ever the
reason is there's competition between
the oil companies and the oil companies
will try to undercut one another you
know you're driving down the street you
see two gas stations they almost always
have the same price
maybe and if one lowers the price a
little bit what happens the other one
lowers the price a little bit too and if
there's one down the street that's even
lower then the the two companies right
here they're gonna have to lower their
prices because there's competition and
whoever's offering the lowest prices
that's that's the company that's going
to get people's business
so she's saying no look you can't you've
got you all need to bring the prices
down and stop being so greedy
corporate greed is the big problem here
as opposed to what as opposed to the
usual policy of corporate altruism
of course that isn't what changed the
oil companies are competing with one
another they're trying to undercut one
another they're trying to maximize their
profits and one of the way to maximize
their profits is to undercut the other
guys on prices to be competitive in the
marketplace none of that has changed
that was true before the war in ukraine
that was true during the war in ukraine
it's it's just as true today the thing
that has changed is the energy policy of
the united states and the foreign policy
that's driving it all up but the the
biden administration can't address any
of that or at least they don't want to
and so they say no it's you no it's you
no it's you the buck stops with
everybody
but me
when you want to protect your retirement
what are you going to do you've got to
go check out alto ira right now go to
altoira.com
michael
insider intelligence estimates that by
the end of 2022 the number of u.s adults
who own at least one cryptocurrency will
climb 19 to 33.7 million
people some surveys show that as many as
85 of millennial millionaires own crypto
how about you do you own any if you
don't and you're not sure where to start
you should check out alto ira alto
offers alternative investment
opportunities such as private companies
crypto funds real estate venture capital
and more alto ira in particular is a
great way to start investing in trading
in crypto with a tax advantaged
retirement account no commissions no
paperwork no set up charges auto makes
investing in crypto so incredibly easy
even i can do it just create your
account transfer the funds start
investing done they're integrated with
coinbase you get secure trading 24 7 150
plus available coins on their interface
including bitcoin ethereum cardano
multiple ways to fund your account it
makes it super duper easy go to alto
crypto ira right now you can start your
account with as little as ten dollars
alto ira.com michael a l t o i r a dot
com slash michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today that is altoira dot
com slash michael
green jean-pierre the white house has no
answer on
energy and because that's the big driver
of inflation they've got no answer on
inflation they don't even have an answer
on the baby formula shortage remember
that remember a couple of weeks ago
you got for a little bit a handful of
headlines
pointing to this crisis in the united
states
mothers can't get formula for their
babies so reporter asks the white house
about that
here's the white house's answer
so i have two questions on baby formula
so first what is the white house what is
the latest update the white house has
received on the current formula
situation across the country yeah let me
see if i have anything new for you on
that uh
cuz i think it's been a couple of days
since we have asked to ask that question
okay
i don't have anything new i know we made
some announcements last week i don't i
just don't have them in front of me
are you kidding me
something tells me karine jean-pierre
the white house broadly they weren't
great in school
well we know joe biden wasn't great in
school he lied about his academic record
in 1988 and he graduated toward the
bottom of his class but i don't think
any of these guys were good in school
specifically because
of how they're trying to stall when they
don't know the answer you know the
teacher says hey johnny what happened in
chapter four of war and peace it says
um
chapter four
yeah chapter four okay you want me to
answer what's in it and you're trying uh
war and peace then you start in you're
stalling and then the idea of stalling
for time is you can make something up
you can have some kind of answer what
happens here with karine jean-pierre
they say hey um i've got a really basic
question about an urgent problem for
lots and lots of americans of all social
classes around the country
oh yeah uh
um hold on um
let me baby uh okay baby formula yeah
just one hold on let me just get to what
oh yeah i have nothing i have nothing i
have no answer i've given this not even
a moment's thought because what the
white house
what's running through the white house's
mind right now on this issue is
oh you guys are still on about that
oh you you annoying little mothers
you're still whining about how you can't
feed your babies why i want to talk
about really important things like
electric cars
oh you all are still oh this is so
annoying i want to talk about stuff that
really matters like transgendering the
children
like pride month i want to talk about
the really important not feeding not
feeding your children no no
we want to trans your children if you
want to talk about child issues that's
something we need to talk about why we
need to let men swim on the women's swim
team their priorities are just so out of
whack here
the baby formula shortage is affecting
huge portions of america
cuts across virtually every demographic
transgenderism is an important issue to
like seven people
and what does the white house focus on
it's all these other issues they're
annoyed
hey could you could you guys fix
inflation stop bothering me about
inflation that doesn't matter i want to
deal with climate change
and people are noticing and it's not
just right-wing republicans and it's not
not just conservatives it's people from
across the political spectrum speaking
of babies
it's a really important story and it's
getting no attention at all of course
there are 23 pro-life organizations that
have been attacked firebombed
vandalized in recent weeks catholic vote
put together a list breitbart's
reporting on it too
the south broward pregnancy center
in hollywood florida the archdiocese of
miami respect life ministry in asheville
north carolina the mountain area
pregnancy services manassas virginia
first care women's health alexandria
virginia concerned women for america
risers town maryland alpha pregnancy
center the list goes on and on and on
maryland new york wisconsin texas
california oregon
washington all over the place all over
the place we have attacks on the
pro-life centers you have if you've
heard a word about it you've heard it on
this show or on a handful of other
conservative media outlets you almost
certainly have not heard this from the
establishment media
if even one
planned parenthood center
had even one
angry guy yelling a little too loudly
outside of it it would be wall-to-wall
coverage
you'd probably have the fbi involved
this would be a grave insurrection
threat to democracy attack on women's
health domestic terrorists they'd
probably be thrown in the solitary
confinement cell next to the the horn
hat guy from january 6 or next to the
dad who cracked a coors light in the
capital rotunda that's the degree of
intense terrorism insurrection we'd be
talking about
meanwhile
23 pro-life centers
almost two dozen torched vandalized
arson spray paint everywhere
nothing
nothing so just know that i don't you
don't need to go out and chat from the
rooftops think of the hypocrisy you know
the thing that i actually i just did
which is imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot that's that's not going to
help anything the reason why it's
important for
you and i to at least acknowledge that
is to just remember
none of the coverage that we're going to
see in the media is fair
none of it is a reflection of reality
when
in the
we hope overruling of roe v wade when
you hear about all the hideous awful
terrible attacks and the threat to just
know it's all fake it's all bs the
people who are ringing their their hands
about this and clutching their pearls
these are people who are are neglecting
who are ignoring and who are in some
cases encouraging attacks on pro-life
centers these are people who kill babies
okay so there is
there is no moral high ground for them
here they are not playing fair and
square this is not a good faith fight
they are they are launching a very
deceptive dishonest political operation
and when they play the victim
they are
they are trying to distract you
from the real victims here
the pro-life centers and the babies of
course
of course speaking of violence
speaking of media cover-ups that people
are still finding out about even though
the media are trying to cover it up
is a gang member
in la who killed two cops a couple of
nights ago
a really really sad story
had it happen this is what makes it even
sadder the gang member was able to go
kill those two cops
because he was out on probation and he
was out on probation because of la's
weak on crime
district attorney
gascon
the story came from bill malugen
uh that gang member who shot these two
el monte pd officers
was on probation for felo for felony
with a firearm so it's not it's not as
though he was on probation for a
jaywalking it was felony with a firearm
he received a bare minimum sentence in a
play deal under george gascon last year
despite having a previous strike on his
record
when we say oh no we've got this bad
liberal government oh no we've got these
bad liberal prosecutors who refuse to
prosecute crime oh no we keep losing
elections
or we we keep having
terrible people installed in these
positions of power
there are very real world consequences
to that if this dude george gascon had
not become the district attorney of los
angeles probably those two el monte
police officers would be alive today
depends it depends who the other d.a
would be but if you had i mean george
gascon is so radically on the side of
the criminals that it's it's hard to say
that that anyone else could could have
been anywhere nearly as bad
so if you had not george gascon in that
position
very likely you'd have this thug
gangster still rotting in prison those
two cops would still be alive those are
very practical consequences
you see it throughout the economy had
the election turned out differently had
the vote counting turned out differently
and trump had won we would be in a much
better position right now probably putin
would not have invaded ukraine that's
what zelinski seems to believe because
zelensky in ukraine thinks that the
reason that putin invaded was because
the trump sanctions were lifted off of
the russian oil pipeline
and that's what gave putin the green
light to invade
biden himself literally gave putin the
green light to invade he said well as
long as it's just a minor incursion we
won't do anything so we're basically
rolling out the red carpet for the guy
if putin had not invaded ukraine do you
think energy prices would be anywhere
near where they are today not not even
close and by the way even if there was
some kind of pressure for them to go up
trump was supportive of the keystone
pipeline which means he was supportive
of
more pipelines right when you shut down
keystone it's not just one pipeline
you're saying the government won't back
any new pipelines when you support it
you're saying the government will back
new pipelines
trump was supportive of oil and gas he
would not have canceled the new oil and
gas leases the energy prices would be
much lower you would be saving a lot of
money at the pump things
these
what seem like minor moments in history
oh well the election went the wrong way
have huge effects for everybody
so it's enough we're so riled up these
days you sometimes just want to sit back
and relax and watch a good movie you can
do that now
with terror on the prairie terra on the
prairie is the uncanceling of gina
carano
the movie is terrific there's some
really great acting they're really
beautiful shots head on over to
dailywire.com gina to become a member
and watch the movie today that's
dailywire.com
gina also tomorrow we've got the
voicemail back you can write in your
regular mailbag questions but you should
also send in your voicemail bed
questions go to my page on the daily
wire site click send in a mailbag
question just record it on your phone or
your computer the audio file send it in
attach it as as an attachment to that
email keep it under 60 seconds if you
don't mind sometimes people want to tell
me their whole life story and we don't
have time for that in the show so send
it in i look forward to hearing your
mellifluous voices we'll be right back
with a lot more
there is a recall effort to take this
terrible district attorney in los
angeles george gascon out of office
because even though you're not hearing a
ton of coverage of these stories the
crime running through the streets in los
angeles the two cops who were killed
because some thug was let out on bail
because of gascon you're not hearing a
lot about that
uh unless you're listening to this show
and others
others on the conservative side but
people still know even the people who
heaven for fend never tune in to the
michael noel's show i feel really bad
for those people by the way there are
people seriously there are people in los
angeles and elsewhere around the country
who have not listened to the michael
knowles show and frankly it's too
that makes me feel a great deal of pity
and sorrow for them so if you wouldn't
mind please copy the link to the to the
show
email it to all of your friends send it
maybe even send a postcard with the link
right written on it i feel bad for these
people you you know you get to be here
but these these poor deprived people
anyway i digress there are people who
don't listen to this show and the
handful of other conservative media
outlets who cover this who still know
they still know even if all they read is
the new york times and the washington
post and all those stupid papers
they still know
crime is way up la is a lot more
dangerous right now there's
drug paraphernalia on the streets
sometimes there are even more disgusting
things on the streets they just know
it's gotten bad
and so there is now an effort the recall
d.a george gascon campaign
has just announced that it has surpassed
566 857 signatures collected as of june
14th that reason that number is
important that equates to 10 of la
voters
which means that they can now officially
initiate a recall now they actually need
more signatures than this because the
libs are going to do everything they can
to cross signatures off of this list
it's so funny because the libs talk a
really good game about how we need every
vote to count and every person to
participate in our democracy and you
shouldn't have to have an id to vote and
anyone should be able to vote and you
should be able to allow your votes to be
harvested by a lot of democrat
operatives until it's the republicans
doing it and then all of a sudden you
say cross him off oh that little old
lady wants to recall gascon i don't
think so we're going to cross her off
the list and they're going to go through
and they're going to take off as many
signatures as they can usually for
technicalities he didn't write his
address correctly that signature looks a
little bit off oh actually that address
is out of date and so we're going to
cross that out too
they need a buffer and they're good
they're probably going to get a buffer i
think
ultimately the goal is to submit 650 000
to 700 000
total signatures george gascon should be
quaking in his boots
because it just happened up in san
francisco san francisco that town is 150
democrat at this point and they had a
similarly
radical d.a very pro-criminal d.a
jaisa boudin
and that guy not only had a recall
initiated against him he got recalled
even the democrats even up in san
francisco said nope sorry we're done
we're done by boudin
we we prefer our prosecutors to
prosecute people that's the job and
gascon is worse than boudin he should be
quaking in his boots the democrats
generally should be a little nervous
assuming that we can figure out election
integrity which i think we broadly can
there are still some challenges on
election integrity the democrats used
covet as an opportunity to get rid of a
lot of the election integrity measures
in this country so it is much easier for
democrats to steal elections now than it
was three years ago but still
we've tightened some things up around
the country
there was a huge win the other night in
texas
this is texas's 34th congressional
district this is in the rio grande
valley
since 1870
democrats have held this congressional
district
1870 and then you know what happened
we got a republican
myra flores won the special election on
tuesday night
uh this will be the first time a
republican's held the seat in over 150
years and by the way this will be the
first person ever born in mexico who
serves in the united states congress
and she is a republican and that is
probably going to drive the democrats
crazy because the democrats say that
we're all a bunch of white supremacists
nazi we hate the mexicans and then
they're looking at the polls and they
say wait why are all the mexicans
starting to vote for the republicans
why why are all the hispanics broadly
moving
pretty dramatically into the republican
camp depending on what opinion poll
you're looking at right now you are
seeing a huge shift where republicans
theoretically
could win the hispanic vote
i wish the numbers were like 80
90
for the republicans but still the the
democrats have been banking on this idea
that they can just win all the minority
votes the coalition of the ascendant and
the republican party is just going to be
the party of of old white men and
they're going to die off thankfully and
we're going to work they've got a
demographic cliff that they're falling
off of and the democrats have been
bragging about this for 20 years and now
we're seeing some chinks in that armor
now we're seeing some wait a second huh
wait the first mexican-born member of
congress is a republican it's down in a
district that the democrats held for 152
years yikes man this is probably a
pretty scary year
for the democrats
you can't even say by the way that it
was just some weird quirky election
where the democrats split the vote or
something like that flores won this is a
special election to replace an outgoing
member of congress and so
the
it's it's a kind it is a weird one in
that you had both parties running in the
same election you had multiple
candidates but you had two republicans
and two democrats
if it were one republican and two
democrats you might say well the dems
split the vote
but no there's two republicans two
democrats and this lady won and now
now she is going to take that seat and
she might be a harbinger of things to
come this could be an historic year
for the gop
for the the balance of power in congress
and for hispanic voters this might this
could be the year
where hispanic voters start to really
seriously shift to the gop it has
happened to other immigrant groups this
is what happened to the italians
the italians come to america
and they
basically split up their votes
they're a little bit more conservative
in some ways i say this with some
firsthand experience of the
italian-american culture
but you've got you've got people like
scalia
right-wing republican you got people
like pelosi left-wing democrat
you got people like
michael canole over here you've got
people like andrew cuomo who's a
left-wing democrat
you you can't really
tell how an italian american is going to
vote just because his last name ends in
a vowel when it comes to hispanics until
very recently you could
and there are a number of reasons for
this that have been suggested part of it
is that while the italian americans were
strongly encouraged to assimilate
sometimes at the back of a paddle they
were encouraged to assimilate
during the most recent waves of hispanic
immigration to america they were they've
actually been discouraged from
assimilating the numbers have been so
massive
migration has been so massive that there
hasn't been a lot of cultural force to
assimilate
and so politically they remain very
similar that might be changing
the way you know the libs are really
nervous about this
they're buying up the spanish stations
i mentioned this a little bit yesterday
so george soros
funding a lot of this
george soros has a media consortium that
is trying to buy up a lot of spanish
radio stations because
the libs are seeing that the the
hispanic voters are moving to the right
and they say oh we can't have this so
we're gonna buy up the spanish stations
and then kick off the conservative
content censor the conservatives there
maybe push some left-wing propaganda and
hopefully that'll stop the bleeding i'm
not convinced that it will but it's a
it's a good strategy
it's a smart strategy the only i'm i
think conservatives should push back
against this obviously and go in and
make sure we've got our own spanish
stations and push our own
messages to the hispanic voters but the
very fact that soros and the crew are
doing this
this is good it means they're genuinely
worried about about the democrats losing
that hispanic vote by the way i do have
to address this because anytime you
mention george soros now
in in recent years you're called a wacky
crazy conspiracy theorist who probably
hates the jews and is you know believes
that there are martians from planet
zebulon who are i guess they'd be from
planet mars controlling the world and
you're you know you're a tin foil hat
crazy person
the simple fact is
george soros wields a lot of political
influence
remember the the
democrats used to demagogue about the
koch brothers and rightly so the koch
brothers spent a ton of money in
republican politics so i get why they
would focus on the koch brothers well
the same at least is true of george
soros george soros is a major maybe the
major
figure in left-wing financing
i actually had this very strange
experience back in my wayward youth i
was taking all sorts of odd jobs in new
york i ended up working as a
sort of fake sommelier
at george soros's wedding i got hired
for this live event thing they didn't
tell me what it was at first and so i
ended up there i was so funny this is
also how i know george soros doesn't
completely control the world is they
clearly hadn't vetted me they didn't
even look up my voter registration so i
end up there and this is george soros's
wedding i think he had three separate
days of weddings and in this room you
had nancy pelosi you had samantha power
you had kofi annan you had bono of
course you had
people from the imf you had people from
all over the world who were sitting
there many many other very influential
people from our country and elsewhere
show up to the middle of westchester
county to go to george soros's wedding
why because he's very very powerful and
he's got a lot of money and he throws it
around in politics it's not a conspiracy
theory it might be a conspiracy but it's
not a conspiracy theory
and they're very very nervous now
speaking of
big endorsements speaking of good
momentum for the gop and republican
politicians
speaking of billionaires throwing their
weight around in politics elon musk has
just
thrown his weight around a little bit he
has suggested that he will be backing
florida governor ron desantis in 2024
elon musk so what i would say um you
know i'm focused on 2022 uh but with
elon musk what i would say is you know i
welcome support from african americans
what can i say
great answer
i assume he had that one in the back of
his head maybe it was off the cuff
really really good answer
he he did that politician thing where he
says look i'm not focused on 2024 wink
wink nudge nudge
i'm focused on 2022 i'm focused on the
state of florida even though i'm
involved in national issues every single
day and he knows he knows he's got an
incredible amount of support right now
to run for president he's by far the
best governor in america and so he's
proving himself every single day but he
doesn't want to get too out ahead of it
here don't forget it's only 2022.
so so what does he do he makes a little
joke about it and he makes a little
politically incorrect joke too
it's not it's just a little haha oh
you're talking about that
african-american over there elon musk
anyway yeah that's cool i'm glad he
supports me i'm focused on florida don't
worry don't worry about it so why is he
doing this
i think this is
the smartest strategy that desantis
could be pursuing right now
ron desantis knows
if he is ever going to have a moment
this is his moment
this is it
the way he handled kovid the way he
continues to handle the economy in
florida the way that people are pouring
into florida from all around where are
they moving they're moving to texas
tennessee and florida
looking at a very weak incumbent joe
biden his own party doesn't like him an
extremely weak vice president fewer
people like the vice president somehow
than like this extremely unpopular
president
desantis is looking and saying this
could be it this could be desantis time
baby but there's one hold up here which
is
trump
trump
could stop desantis from getting the
nomination very easily by the way and he
knows that
trump was a one-term president who wants
his redemption he is hinted to more than
hinted he's flat out told people that he
is going to run in 2024
and so what can desantis do here he
doesn't want to go head-to-head with
trump
but he could miss his moment and so what
he's doing is he's getting ahead of
trump
he's starting to meet with those donors
he's starting to clearly attract some of
those big donors he's putting himself
out there in the news cycle every single
day so that if momentum builds for
desantis right now it's not building as
the anti-trump momentum it's just
building
it's just it's just it's just pro-ron
it's not anti-don
so if if trump is going to run in 2024
he he's in a tough spot right now
because desantis
you see a race begin just to scoop up
money there's a limited amount of money
for
for republicans for democrats too for
anyone who's running for president
there's a limited amount of money out
there and so people have to get those
those commitments early on they've got
to get those endorsements early on
they've got to build that momentum early
on
if trump really does want to run
he's got to get ahead of desantis
because right now desantis is playing
his cards so
perfectly
it's uh it's it's hard to imagine how it
could be going any better for him and
this is still two years out but things
move fast things move very fast in
politics politics is all about
timing
politics is all about
timing joe biden used to have a much
better sense
of timing
than he does now don't forget
joe biden he ran in 1988 he got laughed
out of the race
he didn't run again for 20 years and
then people forgot about 88 he runs
again then he gets vice president then
he waits he thinks 16 is not the year to
do it okay 20 20. now he's going to do
it it's all about
timing
and
whatever timing joe biden previously had
his old age his senility it's it's not
working for him anymore sometimes people
are a little bit
past their time they're a little bit
past their prime they're sort of like
joe biden just pretty clearly not the
man for the moment
i'm also proud to have signed an
executive order my first day in office
to combat discrimination against
lgbtqli excuse me plus
americans
q lgbtqp l i huh what is it elemento huh
anyway pride it's just it's this is
bad news for him
this this stumble on a clip is by is
far from being the most egregious gaff
that biden has made probably even this
week but the reason it matters is it
just shows you how out of step he is
with his party he doesn't know he
doesn't know what the trans and the pans
and the guadalajara bing bam is he
doesn't know any of that
he's not addressing the issues that the
democrats want he is just a placeholder
he was put in there to be an empty suit
and he used to be very good at
channeling the energy of the moment this
is why joe biden's positions have
changed on every single issue over time
is because he doesn't actually believe
anything for his whole career he's been
a weather bank when he was much younger
he was way better at being a weather
vane now he's a little rusty now when
the wind blows it's not that quick
now i'm in this now i believe this is
about marriage now i believe that now as
now i think this is about crime now i
think the opposite about crime it used
to be really really now it's just sort
of like
you know the wind is blowing very very
hard from the west from from the left
side of his room
and lgbt it doesn't
it doesn't work
so you got a really weak incumbent
you've got absolutely nobody on the
democrat bench who's supposed to replace
him
kamala no
buddha judge no stop trying to make
buddha judge happen it's not going to
work no one likes bootage edge
who elizabeth warren her time is totally
over amy klobuchar
she's probably got the best shot out of
anyone i just named but that's she
doesn't have much of a shot so that's
sort of sad hillary that maybe they're
going to drag hillary out again so she
can lose a tenth time she can
they just every year they're just going
to bring out hillary so she can lose
again this is a great opportunity for
republicans
if if someone is thinking about running
for office
very often they'll think okay where
should i run what office should i run
for an even more important question
frankly is when
should i run
if it's a big wave year
chances of winning that lower that
congressional seat that even that senate
seat
the state senate seat for goodness sakes
increases dramatically
so you got to find the timing sometimes
you got to wait wait wait and then you
jump on it that's what's happening right
now in alaska
race is not getting a lot of play but
alaska
has one congressional district and has
one politician
who is more famous than any other up
there that would be of course sarah
palin sarah palin
is running
for congress
and sarah palin is absolutely crushing
it
she won in the first round of voting for
alaska's congressional seat special
election 54.4
of the vote when that by the time that
had come in palin had 32 000 votes
to just over 20 000 for the second place
finisher uh she's she's doing right
she's absolutely crushing it the field
included 48 different candidates to
replace representative dun young who
died in march
and so now the top candidates will go on
they'll go to the next round of the
state's first ever ranked choice
non-partisan primary
so the the
parties don't really matter it's going
to be ranked choice it's going to be
kind of weird
it's weird in a different way but still
weird sort of like that that race down
in texas where the
prominent
republican woman
lots of momentum lots of energy where
she won as well
i was trying to think about what i feel
about sarah palin i don't know sarah
palin
sarah palin was the vice presidential
candidate
just around the time that i started to
really become involved in politics even
frankly a little bit before i was really
involved working on campaigns that sort
of thing
what do i think about sir i don't know
that much about sarah palin do you
follow alaska politics very closely
probably not
and yet
just deep in my gut
i like sarah palin
i was trying to figure out why do i like
sarah palin i don't really know that
much about her career
i don't haven't followed her very much
since she left
the presidential vice presidential
campaign trail i know she's done some
weird tv shows and things i haven't paid
attention to that so why do i like her i
like sarah palin
because they hate sarah palin
that's why that's what it comes down to
i don't know maybe sarah palin has some
problems but my gut tells me i am
inclined to like this woman because all
the right people hate her
and that's usually a pretty good rule of
thumb in politics right now
another prominent republican woman
lauren bobert is coming under fire i
think completely ridiculous spurious
attacks trying to oust her you know end
of the campaign surprise kinds of of
nonsense
i think why do i like lauren bober i
actually am friends with lauren bobert i
so i you know i've gotten to spend some
time with her personally i like her from
you know
what we've what we've
how we've interacted and the things that
i followed her do in congress but even
if i didn't even if i had never met
lauren bobert i didn't know anything
about her record i would still be
inclined to like lauren bobert why
because all the right people hate her
that's a good guide that is a good guide
to things because the people who hate
sarah palin and who hate lauren bobert
and who hate donald trump and who hate
ted cruz and who hate rhonda santas and
who hate all these guys
those people are wrong about pretty much
everything
do you think that
dr fauci likes sarah palin probably not
do you think joe bought well we know joe
biden do you think any of these people
and and politics is
in many ways a team sport
it has to be that's why we have parties
that's why we have elections that
because you can't it shouldn't just be a
team sport it has to it also has to have
something to do with reason and justice
and the truth and a role for
individuality breaking out of some stale
old talking points for goodness sakes
trump certainly did that in 2016. but
you need to come together as a team
and there's a reason there's a reason
why people who are pro-life
also
support economic growth there is a
reason why
people who
support american traditions and the
traditional american family also support
secure borders i know it seems like
those are different issues but they're
not they have a coherence they
they
they
they say something about what we believe
about philosophy and theology and the
relation of man to the state there's
there's a kind of coherence to that okay
you actually
can
judge a man by his enemies
and right now this is a story we can't
get to i'll have to get to it tomorrow
gw george washington university has just
voted to get rid of its mascot who's a
guy who looks like george washington
called the colonial
the colon and they're voting to get rid
of that because they hate washington
they hate the colonials they hate amer
america's founding the people who hate
lauren bobert and sarah palin and donald
trump and all these people they also
hate george washington they want to tear
down his statues and christopher
columbus and all they
they are just
they've got a bad view of the world and
so
especially in an election year i am very
inclined
to look at where my where my enemies and
my opponents
are moving the people they're afraid of
the people they're pushing back hardest
against those are the people that i'm
going to defend those are the people
that i'm going to stand
on the side with and hopefully win i'm
michael knowles this the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show the
federal reserve boosts interest rates by
75 basis points for the first time since
1994 even as retail sales unexpectedly
declined plus joe biden hosts an
lgbtq plus minus divided by sign
celebration at the white house while
announcing government action to trans
the kids that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen